So let's talk about just the crazy story out
of Mississippi, a Mississippi election commissioner
was caught on Facebook, I guess caught.
I mean, I don't know if that's even the right
word.
A posting on Facebook that the blacks are
registering to vote and that Mississippians
need to do something about it, sort of implying
that the blacks in Mississippi aren't really
the Mississippians.
Obviously, this woman who did this is white.
Now, for context, Mississippi is a state in
trouble.
If you look at American states ranked by Human
Development Index, which is a sort of composite
statistic of life expectancy, education and
per capita income.
Mississippi is dead last.
If you look at health care rankings, Mississippi
is dead last or sometimes forty eighth or
forty ninth.
If you look at education rankings, Mississippi
is 46.
So Mississippi is a place with some serious
problems.
Black folks make up a large percentage of
the Mississippi population.
And good for them.
They're registering to vote.
They're holding voter registration drives.
They plan to vote so that they can help their
state improve.
In other words, you don't vote to ruin your
state.
You vote to improve your state by having a
say in what it is that who is going to lead
you in what it is that they're going to do.
Jones County Election Commissioner Gail Harrison
Welch posted on Facebook that she's concerned
that lots of the blacks are registering to
vote.
That's it.
That's her concern.
There's no caveat.
She says, quote, I'm election.
So I'm reading it as she wrote it.
I'm.
Election commissioner in Jones County.
I'm concerned about voter registration in
Mississippi.
The blacks are having lots of events for voter
registration.
People in Mississippi have to get involved,
too, to thank you for all you do.
By the way, before we get on this, this is
super funny.
A guy named John Welch who shares her last
name and appears to be a family member, responded
to her Facebook comment by saying, quote,
Gail, you are no longer welcome at family
Reub reunion's.
About 60 years ago, all parts of the Welch
family faced a choice.
Racism or Americanism.
The Virginia side of the Welch family from
the Shenandoah chose America.
You are plainly wrong, which is absolutely
hilarious to see her family's dirty laundry
aired on Facebook.
But eventually, because this was a public
post on Facebook, she was confronted about
her statement by the local newspaper, The
Clarion Ledger, and she said, quote, I don't
mean anything by it.
I've worked hard to make sure everybody is
registered to vote black or white, everybody.
That's just how I am now.
In my experience, most people who refer to
the blacks doing something do mean something
by it that is racially tinged, if not straight
up racist.
And also when she says the blacks are having
lots of events to register voters, people
in Mississippi have to get involved, too.
It is obviously implying that she sees black
Mississippians as not really the people of
Mississippi.
It's the white people in Mississippi that
are really the people of Mississippi.
Now, her other excuse, and this is crazy because
it's not an excuse her other excuse was the
message was meant to be sent as a private
message on Facebook.
It wasn't meant to be public.
I hate to break it to you.
All that means is you had the sense to realize
it shouldn't be public.
It should be private in order to avoid more
scrutiny.
But it doesn't make it any less racist or
any more outrageous.
And the real tragedy, and this is the sort
of circling around the real tragedy, is she
still has this position in Jones County in
Mississippi.
She said this in a state that is more than
30 percent black and she is still an election
official in Jones County, Mississippi, at
least as of this morning.
And if that changes, I will certainly let
you know.
But this is you know, the right has this idea
that calling someone racist is the worst thing
you can do.
And they've actually weaponized claims of
racism against those who make the claims.
You see this very frequently where they've
also they've all almost made it taboo.
They've tried to make it taboo to claim to
see racism.
And they very often say that seeing racism
is the racism or seeing racism as, quote,
playing the race card.
That's like the phrase Trump derangement syndrome.
These are phrases meant to just shut down
debate.
They say on the right that the left wants
to shut down debate.
When you tell anybody who has identified an
act of racism that the problem is then mentioning
it, that is a form of shutting down debate.
Similarly, there's this phrase you're suffering
from TADS Trump derangement syndrome.
When somebody on the Internet will make a
criticism of Donald Trump.
Trump supporters will pop up and they'll say,
you're suffering from Trump derangement syndrome.
This is a way to just shut down the debate.
You're disqualifying the person making the
criticism as just being blinded by hatred
of Trump and being unable to speak coherently.
What you're actually doing is you're shutting
down the person and not even having to defend
against the claims.
That's the same type of thing that we see
with, oh, you've identified racism.
You're the person who is actually racist.
She is still an election official in Mississippi.